I run this this team of I like to think
of them as persuasion scientists at the
Wall Street Journal at Dow Jones more
broadly and if you go to whi comm where
you go to our apps if you go to Berens
comedy but burns apps you're probably in
an experiment that we're running and
I've been doing this for about three
years now the team started with about
two of us now we're up to five we're
hiring a couple more people next year
it's obviously just been really fun
testing is if if you're unsure of it
testing is really really fun it's
extremely validating right you just get
this this immediate gratification and
there's just this this beautiful
customer feedback loop that you're
basically just trying to harness and and
interpret so where do we test and what
do we test for back in 2015 the
subscription business essentially went
through a digital transformation where
they said we need to kind of read jigger
things and set ourselves up for more
digital growth and so there were a
number of changes one of them was that
they made this this little team and they
said here's some money and go do some
testing and that's about that's about
all the guidance we we had and that's
about all we needed but the best place
to start any testing or experimentation
program is on the acquisition side right
it's really difficult to to screw up
your results or to not figure out when
you did something good or orders more
money is just usually a good thing so we
spent more than a year just focused on
solving for acquisition but of course
then we realized testing is something
that all you really need is you need a
digital moment he'd lots of traffic and
you need to know what you want people to
do so you can basically apply it to any
digital experience as long as you've
you've got all those things lined up so
we moved up the funnel on to the
editorial site but for people who were
unsubscribed so trying to trying to
change that experience and optimize that
experience so we could get increase the
conversion rate from content and then
also moving down the funnel where
obviously all of you guys are are
extremely well aware that onboarding is
a critical Accord
where you can really sort of set up your
members your your users for success or
for failure and again we've pushed out
again in 2018 we've partnered with the
core product team which is sort of the
stewards of just what it means to
consume Wall Street Journal content so
we're solving just for real kind of true
product KPIs
we're gonna add some more we're teaming
up with the retention team we're teaming
up with the education team so we're just
kind of getting our our tendrils out
across the business where there's sort
of the stakeholder who has the real
ownership of the real estate or the the
business outcome and we try to
facilitate them achieving that by
because we're we become experts at the
discipline of experimentation another
way to look at it is you look at the
metrics that were actually solving for
they've obviously exploded so how do we
choose what to test now I don't know
in this room would you guys who here
feel here isn't doing any a B
multivariate testing okay great
who feels like they're who feels like
there's just starting out okay so we're
yeah we're we're in we're further along
the the curve regardless of where you
are these are these three slides I think
are the most important slides in terms
of I think driving the success that
we've seen the first thing is that we
three years in we are still obsessively
hunting the low-hanging fruit there is
this this thing that happens where once
businesses become committed to making
data-driven decisions they often over
rotate towards getting thing making
things really complicated and really
fancy really soon because if it's
fancier and it's more complicated and it
seems harder it seems better but in fact
the right business is difficult so
anytime things are easy you want to hold
on for all it's worth so I think and I
think there's been this sort of
misconception where where the act of
segmenting and personalizing experience
is that's what represents the biggest
upside when it comes to experimentation
and just you know manipulating digital
experiences when in fact what we've
found you
that these the one-size-fits-all
learnings right basic navigation basic
design evergreen copy that always wins
that's the low-hanging fruit that's
sitting right there and then actually
represent that minimum 50% of the upside
whereas things like segments based
experiences all of those have to work a
lot harder right so for example in my
case if I if I have some theory about
how I could speak to people coming from
opinion content right and I run a test
right a 10% uplift on just people coming
from opinion traffic is he's got to work
ten times as hard as a 10% uplift that
applies every man woman and child who's
considering buying The Wall Street
Journal so that really has I think been
a pretty important driver of our success
then you got personally is a
personalization up here right again
there's plenty of upside there but just
if you if you skip out on this stuff
you're just making it harder on yourself
and as I said we've been doing this for
three years and we're still finding big
one-size-fits-all really stupid simple
learnings so the second thing that I
think has really sort of informed our
strategy is best summed up by this great
quote from Van Gogh small emotions are
the great captains of our lives and
obviously he'd be rolling in his grave
if he knew we were talking and using it
in this context but he's not around so
we're gonna proceed what you're gonna
see in the test that I've selected to
show you guys you're gonna be blown away
by the dramatic impact these subtle
subtle changes and-and-and have had and
I think that the two takeaways are one
the two daggers on that or one that
you're probably there's probably a lot
of upside just lying in plain sight
really close at hand or you don't have
to do that much you don't have to build
a new feature it just could you know you
just try can try to manipulate the
experience as it is in terms of how its
presented so on and so forth and the
second it should also give you pause
anytime you make a change that you
deemed to be large and assume that you
know it's gonna it's gonna be good
because if they're sensitive to things
like this
and anything that's bigger than that
they're they're definitely gonna be
sensitive and you might have got it
wrong so we try to test absolutely
everything before it launches regardless
whether its large or small
the last thing that that has been sort
of surprising to us is I think when you
find yourself in a in a less imaginative
place testing tends to steer itself
towards price and feature right now
obviously those are big very powerful
levers because you're actually changing
the nature of the proposition but
especially on the feature strata that
that stuff is expensive what we've found
is that the vast majority of the
successes we've had have been making
very very simple and very inexpensive
changes to copy InDesign which you know
as you can see instead of the three
buckets on the more on the right side so
again this again this leads you back to
this it leads us back to this instinct
where there's just a lot of there's a
lot of upside just in the window
dressing and not in the meat on the
bones and if you write if you can just
create value essentially out of nothing
just by how you position the product
without having to make any improvement
to the product itself that's just the
easiest money you're ever gonna get
who cares so how does an experimentation
team establish its own value right some
places you've got product managers who
are who are managing the sort of the
core product robot and they're also
testing in our case we sort of have this
standalone unit so we really want to
make sure but he knows if we're doing a
good job so how does in testing group
establishes value they run a test so on
the acquisition side of things we
actually recreated the experience of
subscribing to The Wall Street Journal
back when we began and a B tested it
against the experiences a little bit
dated but the experience you have today
which is essentially the sum total of
all of our learnings as a 64 percent
conversion up right uplift and actually
when you break it out by device the
numbers are much higher the reason why
the blended number drops to 64 is that
mobile traffic the ratio of mobile to
desktop traffic has dramatically shifted
and the conversion rate is just seeing
definitely lower on mobile even though
we've moved it up so there's nothing
wrong with that
so I'm gonna roll into some examples
again think about the thing about the
low-hanging fruit I think there's all
these examples are consistent at their
low-hanging fruit
and that they were we started with
something relatively subtle on the
acquisition side cut the fat add a
little color tell people what you
thought they already knew time and place
so cutting the fat the first thing that
we did was not to have an idea about
what we should add to anything there's a
great Santa group quote which is the
designer knows he's done not when
there's anything to add when there's
nothing left to take away so the first
thing we said is let's not assume we
have any good ideas about what we should
add to any of these experiences let's
look at what we can cut especially when
it comes to forms so this was the
checkout when we when we began it took
about one minute to complete it when you
went as fast you could we cut about 25%
of the just of the field you had to
enter all right that's pure upside you
didn't change the product you didn't do
anything right there's some heavy
lifting involved in terms of some
back-end systems but you didn't have to
be particularly imaginative to to
generate value for your business by
experimenting in this way adding a
little color right so this is the this
was the page that you saw when you
downloaded the Wall Street Journal
Android app on first open when we began
testing in it and it occurred to us that
this sort of grey on grey on grey
illustration wasn't necessarily doing
the best job of painting the picture of
the wonders that awaited you on the
other side of a wall street journal
subscription so we just went to the
marketing department and we said could
you give us a colorized packshot right
let's not assume we know anything let's
not let's not any copy let's keep that's
let's change one variable at a time that
was 110 percent order uplift right so
just put a little spin on the ball right
give it a little pop see what happens
this is a really interesting test so
again this is maybe one of my favorites
because you've got on to the left you've
got an article roadblock and on your
right you've got the the header of our
shop page now we've we've been doing a
really good job of growing the bit the
subscription business in the last couple
of years and one of the components of
that has been a sort of a campaign based
model where every month there's a new
look and feel there's a new price point
there's a new message right there's
always a part
The Wall Street Journal store
effectively right and it's it's been
part of our success right but we started
you know a couple years in we started to
ask ourselves right the wall stiff
there's ever a product that has
perennial value right timeless value
it's a product like The Wall Street
Journal so maybe there's something we
could say in this moment where someone's
coming from a piece of content into a
subscription X you know a subscription
you know purchase decision that could
beat timely messages like this every day
of the year so we thought we we tried a
lot of different things so all these
tests for the record there are lots of
variations I'm just showing you the one
that one for the purposes of time but we
we have run lots of tests that lose this
is not a my attempt at a victory lap
your unlocks that's to lose and within
tests that win there are lots of
variations that also lose but one of the
things we tried was he tried to think of
the dumbest simplest stupidest thing we
could say in this moment which feels
like a huge waste of time right this is
your moment and we burned all this
marketing real estate to tell people
something which should be patently
obvious because they just clicked an
article and they just got this big blue
thing in that's in the way of it but we
repeated ourselves or so we thought
continue reading continue reading your
article of the WCA membership that was a
37% order uplift from articles so just
just trying to try to come up with the
simplest customer empathy and working
back from their time in place so for
time immemorial we've The Wall Street
Journal has had a CTA strategy right the
words that sit on our buttons at every
point in the acquisition funnel that
said join now and act now now obviously
we just had a chance to test it we know
that a an ad on social or article
roadblock or a shop page or a checkout
flow are all very very different
psychological moments so we started to
started of digging to that that that
premise so this is an article roadblock
so at that point what's actually
happened is that they've actually
expressed no interest in subscribing to
the Wall Street Journal whatsoever all
they did was they say they wanted to
read an article and they found it they
couldn't unless they paid us so we
thought in this moment we're not
actually we don't want implicit enjoin
or implicit an act is the effort of
filling out a form and the pain of
parting with your hard earned cash when
in fact all we really want to do
you should we want you to do something
that should be fun which is to
window-shop we just want you to come in
the store and poke around see if
something makes sense for you
so we softened the language to view
membership options that was an 18% order
uplift from content again simple simple
simple on the engagement side we also
had some fun wins I had to cut these for
time also for the record these timers
are not working so I have no idea where
I'm at but yeah okay cool
make sure the pipes are connected again
I think one thing we're really good at
is just taking the same experience and
just staring at it over and over again
turning it on its side turning on its
side relentlessly reanalyzing and
reimagining these moments that we know
are sort of critical choke points either
in the concept of acquisition or
engagement make them eat their
vegetables if there are good things that
you know if there are things that you
know will make people happy it's worth
it's worth trying to force it on them
within reason so when it came to the
world of engagement we right unlike
acquisition it's a little bit harder to
figure out what you want anyone to do
right there's all these you know clearly
doing stuff in your app or on your
website is not is usually not a sign of
bad engagement it is by definition
engagement but in our case from a
subscription perspective we wanted to
make sure we were a little bit more
laser focus so the we realized the only
engagement metric that really mattered
was if they do it do they stay longer
right we need that correlation between
longer tenure for us to be willing to
spend air time trying to get anyone to
do do something and a couple of things
really popped
so newsletter signups if if you have a
group of subscribers who sign up for a
newsletter compared to a group of
survivors who don't nine months later
you'll have 15% more of them if they did
that and obviously on the usage of the
app in addition to the website is even
more I'm even more surprising number so
now we've kind of got our compass points
ready to go so one thing that's that's
interesting is that 80% of our orders on
WCA com come on desktop the conversion
rates so much higher it just the
tactually the traffic ratio is is much
more even but
the end result is much higher on desktop
because the conversion rate just is is
significantly higher up so how do you
get someone on a desktop computer to
download an app and to know that they
did it right now the Android the Android
store does the Play Store does have a
have a good solution around this the iOS
store doesn't are our users tend to skew
a little bit more on the iOS side of
things so we've got this problem where
there's we've figured out the one thing
we want them to do desperately and for
80% of them we don't really we'll never
really know if they did it so you've got
this sort of connection problem so all
we did is we added a little link text
this is this little link texting
functionality it's silly silly stuff you
said you'd enter your cell phone number
it immediately we don't keep the number
we immediately delete it we send you a
text which senses whether you've got an
iOS or Android device and sends you a
link to the appropriate app that was 95
percent lift in app downloads on
onboarding right absolutely nuts just
again just trying to trying to approach
things in a very very simple way the
next thing we did with our with our
onboarding was our onboarding is a
historically was a single sort of static
page and we realized they just came from
a checkout which is mandatory obviously
and card based so we wondered could be
psychologically leveraged this
experience going into onboarding where
this stuff that we really would love
them to do and we know they're gonna
value our product a lot more they're
gonna get much more out of it if they
actually do perform these actions so we
wondered if we could leverage that's
that that experience once we got to
onboarding so we turned onboarding into
a card-based experience so the most
important thing it does is it focused it
focused them in on an a.1 experience at
the TAT a time so right so there their
attention was not divided between the
four things and we obviously were able
to prioritize them in Torreon in order
of benefit to them and to us but the
second thing is just because it was
cautious because it looked card based
and it looked like the checkout it just
felt just mandatory enough even though
right there's a very large skip and
continue button on any of them that
we're able to really get really you know
dramatically increase the rate at which
they're doing all these things which
just enhances the value of
the subscription they just decided to to
purchase and I think that's what all I
got
[Applause]